Sawyer's God is an ambitious college
senior keen on getting her life together
on a morning run she gets a phone call
informing her that she has been
shortlisted for a job interview the news
excites Sawyer immensely but she
realizes that the interview is in
Washington she fears the embarrassment
that would result if she does not get
the job so she secretly attends the
interview Sawyer quickly gathers what
she will need for the trip and cancels
plans to celebrate Thanksgiving with her
family on I-64 Sawyer encounters holiday
traffic so she decides to use an
alternative route the road is partially
closed off after a few miles for safety
reasons desperate Sawyer pulls out a
paper map intending to carve out another
way to Washington she stops by the
roadside and exits the car to start
scoping the map suddenly a truck pulls
up next to her two brothers Hollister
and buck emerge from the car and
approach Sawyer the brothers want to
help Sawyer but they get aggressive when
Sawyer refuses their invitation for
dinner the brothers start attacking
Sawyer but she quickly defends herself
by injuring the guys with a pocket knife
Sawyer runs into the woods desperate to
escape the brothers unfortunately she
falls and injures her leg but
successfully hides from the brothers
when it starts getting dark the brother
sees their search and exit the woods the
brothers had been burying a body when
Sawyer drove past them the paranoid
Brothers assumed that Sawyer had seen
them so they followed her Sawyer finds a
stream and quenches her thirst before
spending a night in the Ravine later
that evening the sheriff's department
received a complaint about an abandoned
car County Sheriff O'Doyle goes out to
investigate he asks a few neighbors
about the vehicle but no one knows
anything finally he comes across the
brothers he is suspicious when he sees
there being a bases but the brothers
deny knowing anything about the
abandoned car the sheriff leaves as he
does not find evidence and support to
the contrary Sawyer continues her hike
in the woods despite feeling weak and
hungry she also deals with a soaring
pain in her leg making it difficult to
make much progress she is by a cliff
when she hears some people conversing in
hushed voices suddenly a car tumbles
down the embarkment Sawyer realizes the
car belongs to her the brothers have
decided to toss it as it might bring
unwanted attention to their business
after they leave Sawyer walks towards
the wrecked car she manages to find her
phone however she is out of cell phone
coverage and her battery is draining
fast so it is useless to her Sawyer
walks around for a while and then she
passes out she's in a house when she
comes to and her wounded leg has been
bandaged before her stands a man named
Lowell Lowell tries to calm Sawyer down
but she gets up adamant to leave she
throws lie in his face but passes out
from the exhaustion before much harm can
be done she finds that Lowell had bound
her feet and hands when she wakes up
Lowell offers her some bread and insists
that he wants to help meanwhile the
brothers keep on tracking Sawyer and
their efforts lead them to Lowell Lowell
is conversing with Sawyer when a car
pulls up outside Sawyer starts screaming
for help but Lowell cautions her against
it as he wants to check the car out the
brothers quickly approached the house
and Lowell walks out it turns out that
the brothers are Lowell's cousins Lowell
is a meth cook who supplies drugs to the
brothers the brothers inquire about
Sawyer but he denies seeing any girl
around the brothers gets vicious when
Lowell fails to invite them inside the
house luckily Sawyer escapes her bonds
and hides outside while the brothers
searched the house after they leave
Sawyer wonders why Lowell protected her
from the brothers Lowell reveals that he
knows his cousins will harm Sawyer if
they find her so keeping her in the
house is the best way to protect her
back in town O'Doyle gets pressure from
his boss Kentucky State Police Commander
Slattery the car's owner has been found
to be a young girl and her disappearance
is a top priority Slattery wants O'Doyle
to handle the case urgently and he is
displeased with how Doyle has dealt with
the issue so far O'Doyle is angered by
the berating he takes before his Deputy
cats in the next scene O'Doyle visits
the brothers it turns out he is a
corrupt cop involved in the Shady meth
dealings he is angry at the brothers for
letting Sawyer Escape alive as this
could immensely affect their operations
he wants the brothers to find Sawyer as
soon as possible after ascertaining that
Lowell is a good guy Sawyer reveals that
she has an interview in Washington she
asks Lowell to let her go but Lowell
does not have a car however his cousins
will be out of town for the weekend so
Lowell will have their truck and can
easily take Sawyer to Washington the two
Bond and become friends over their
shared Agony Lowell shows Sawyer some
chemical tricks while preparing the next
batch of meth the brothers bring some
boxes to Lowell's house so Lowell mixes
some chemicals to fill the house with
white smoke this way Sawyer sneaks out
to hide and the brothers cannot see
anything to indicate her presence due to
the Smoke back in town Deputy Katz
overhears a conversation between O'Doyle
and the brothers he is deeply Disturbed
to learn that the sheriff is behind some
of the worst crimes done in the town he
goes to the sheriff and holds him at
gunpoint the sheriff tries to calm the
deputy down and when cats lets his guard
down the sheriff kills him O'Doyle gets
the brothers to bury cat's body in the
woods when Commander Slattery inquires
about the case O'Doyle discovers some
planted evidence showing that cats had
something to do with the missing girl he
says that he fired cats and he must have
disappeared with Sawyer Slattery feels
that the case is taking too long to
handle he hands the case over to the
state police later O'Doyle meets with
the brothers and updates them on the
situation he is afraid that the state
police will discover the drug business
and arrest them O'Doyle wants the
brothers to handle the next meth
delivery as soon as possible before the
case is handed over he also decides to
help them with the task hoping the money
earned from the dealings will help him
with his retirement Sawyer and Lowell
are hanging outside when o'doyle's car
pulls over Sawyer quickly runs and hides
before the sheriff reaches the house the
sheriff also suspects that Lowell's
hiding Sawyer and he asks to search the
house Lowell holds out his rifle and
refuses to let the sheriff inside his
house saying he needs a warrant O'Doyle
tells the brothers that Lowell might be
a problem if he Harbor Sawyer the
brothers go to Lowell's house and see
Sawyer's footprint confirming that she
is staying there with Lowell they let
themselves in and held the two hostages
at gunpoint Lowell claims he hid Sawyer
from the brothers because he found a
better use for her since the brothers
want to expand their drug business and
upstates the drug cartel moving into the
region they will need larger production
for this he has been training Sawyer to
help and has kept her prisoner in the
house after saying this Lowell instructs
Sawyer to make him some coffee this will
prove that Sawyer has become an obedient
servant Sawyer walks to the kitchen and
prepares the coffee she then places the
coffee mug in the microwave and walks
towards Lowell sitting on his lap a few
minutes later the microwave alarm goes
off indicating that the coffee is ready
Buck walks towards the microwave but a
few seconds later the microwave explodes
with a loud bang it turns out that
Lowell had placed a mixture of anhydrous
ammonia which explodes when heated the
impact kills Buck instantly and injures
everyone else except Sawyer who Lowell
Shields the two crawl outside the Lowell
is badly injured and cannot escape with
Sawyer Lowell urges Sawyer to run just
as Hollister walks out with the rifle he
goes to shoot Lowell but Sawyer
intervenes by grabbing him from the back
Buck's body is half burnt but he's still
stronger than Sawyer Lowell urges Sawyer
to run as she cannot overpower Buck
O'Doyle arrives on the scene and shoots
Lowell and buck Sawyer has escaped while
the trailer was burning as she sighs in
relief when a police car Stomps before
her she gets in the car but quickly
realizes that O'Doyle had lewd and 10
tensions after he uses an idiom she had
heard the brothers used he had murdered
the cousins to ensure that their drug
business would not be linked to him and
now he has one loose end to tie up which
is Sawyer O'Doyle soon realizes that
Sawyer suspects him and he threatens her
he takes Sawyer to the titular rust
Creek and starts assaulting her while
trying to drown her fortunately Sawyer
defends herself using a weeding Fork
that she had grabbed from Lowell's house
earlier the two struggle and the fork
falls into the stream Sawyer struggles
with the bulkier man until she finds the
fork she stabs a Doyle repeatedly on his
feet base and torso this does not
fatally injure him but the stabs are
powerful enough to distract him and he
lets her go Sawyer keeps on attacking
O'Doyle when she is convinced that
O'Doyle won't follow her Sawyer limps
away with determination and she
approaches the road behind her several
police cars pull up and now Sawyer can
breathe easy knowing that her painful
ordeal is done click on one of the two
videos on screen right now
[Music]
foreign